hi everyone welcome to this for Poitras
stream we've just watched magnus carlsen
and very convincing passion beating got
a kusenov I cannot promise that I will
repeat my countrymen's
impressive wins because this is for
player chess I think the only way you
can ever understand the what's going on
is is by actually trying it out so I'm
gonna go for playing a new game and it's
[Music]
basically as bad as it sounds I'm being
told I have some technical difficulties
how about now do we have audio it's my
turn so I've been trying out this this
for Poitras and basically I still have
no idea what's going on I think the gist
of it is that you never want to be
exchanging your pieces because if you
exchange with one of your opponents
they're still gonna be two opponents who
who benefit so if two guys make a trade
then the other the remaining two guys
are the ones really benefitting as they
gonna have more pieces so yeah diagonals
are important King safety I think is
important to be honest with with
everyone I still have not cracked this
game but have actually won quite a few
games but I I still have no idea what
I'm doing so right now I'm basically
putting it as a normal game of chess
developing your pieces taking the center
but the center is somewhat larger than
normal so I'm not sure how much it helps
I've watched Danny branch he has done
some some videos ah look at this blue
just blundered his bishop against black
that's that's not good news so maybe I
can take this opportunity
to distract black and to note to
distract red because he will be busy
taking this bishop and then maybe I can
open up some my diagonals towards oh
okay okay so yellow has just attacked my
pawn here on M 10 let's say b7 to keep
my sanity and I also have this thing
going on here but if I take here them
but red is gonna take back and then I'm
gonna lose this pawn so I actually have
to prioritize this other one and then I
just end up losing my pawn over here
okay so now it has been open up for the
for the Queen so the blue Queen is
actually gonna go down the entire board
and attack me and blue is getting helped
out by yellow they're ganging up on me
so yellow is kicking away my knight so
that blue on the next turn can can take
it yeah every time I win in this game it
just it feels so random it feels like
what was going on and then things kind
of just work out and right now that this
is just a perfect illustration of that
because I have no idea what's going on
okay so yellow is attacking blue so we
see that blue blundered his Bishop quite
early on and therefore he's in massive
trouble and also it means that it's very
beneficial to be close to the blue guy
so that you can give checkmate so how
the game actually works is that you get
points for how many
pieces you take so red is in the lead
with nine points and you get five points
for a bishop five points for a rook one
point for a pod and nine points for a
queen man and this yellow guy keeps
attacking me so I think that's in terms
of formulating a strategy I think making
sure to kind of attack the guy closest
to you has to be the best strategy and
that's precisely what yellow is doing
he's attacking me I really don't know
what I'm doing I suppose let's just go
with a knight
what
I think one of the the main points is
that when you get the pawn over to the
other side you get a new queen and over
to the other side it's a bit of an
overstatement you actually just have to
go with a pawn one two three four five
six steps so I think at this point
having no idea what I'm supposed to do
I'm just gonna run with a pawn I'm just
gonna run with the pawn try to get a new
queen and basically hope for the best I
think one of the it's a bit cynical but
one of the main strategies is just
making sure that nobody nobody really
pays attention to you because if you are
allowed to kind of gradually build up
something or just if you just stay in
the corner and just make sure that none
of your pieces are exchanged then you're
gonna be a decent favorite playing
against all all of your opponents well
you're gonna have more pieces than your
opponent's so while you may not have as
many points as them in the point system
you will have more pieces to take all of
their pieces and that could be good
stuff okay this was a very good move
it's a very good move from from yellow
and because now if I take them if I if I
take this pawn then I'm gonna be checked
actually I think I have a good move here
no that was a terrible okay I my idea
was that now it's not check if he goes
forward but on the other hand she can
just take my pointer
but then again I can take the this point
because now there's this pawn while it's
massively confusing is moving forward as
seen from yellows position and now it's
being blocked by my bishop now he's
threatening my bishop with the night and
I'm gonna move my bishop oh I have a
pawn hanging yeah I totally forgot about
that yeah for play chess is complicated
I don't know how else to put it
do you lose control and there's always
some diagonal you were expecting to that
you miss one diagonal where you're one
of the three of the guys has a bishop
placed way on the other side of the
board and and suddenly it comes into
play and completely ruins everything
yeah I'm just gonna stick to my kind of
meeting strategy let the other guys kill
each other and then I'm gonna kind of
stay in the game to pick up the pieces
because right now yellow castled away
from me so yellow is essentially just
saying that I'm safe my king is safe I'm
very close to blue and blue basically
cannot do anything because he blended
this piece early on and he's just he
basically has no pieces I left to defend
himself I could try to attack bread
right now his king position I think is
looking pretty solid yes I'm just gonna
it's it's a bit of a chicken strategy
but I'm just gonna be the quiet mouse in
the corner and wait for better times
maybe I should try to get my queen into
attacking blue because right now red is
really and he got an extra queen as well
he's really trying to basically gobble
up all of all of blues pieces yeah the
time control is delay so you get like 10
or 15 seconds in which your time doesn't
which doesn't affect your time but once
that time has been used then you have to
move and you have a minute and I
basically spent my entire minute so I'm
gonna need to move faster and moving
fast when you have no plan it's not
great okay it's my turn again
so I threaten yellows Queen he protected
it and then I'm moving back it's such a
sad strategy but at this point I cannot
see how it's also kind of if I start
attacking red then he has two queens so
he might just decide to kill me for
annoying him and that's not good I'm
gonna try to advance my pawns but I have
no control of this diagonal which is
being controlled by the red so I'm gonna
try to gain control over some of these
alight squares and push
to the points forward it's not my turn
right you know the red really has been
having a very good game I don't
understand what was the masterful skill
of his plan he got a new queen he just
pushed that pawn behind the the Queen as
far as he could and he got a new Queen
and blue blundered a bishop but but
other than that it's just odd there's a
Czech interesting but I'm not really
participating in this attack on blue so
I think yellow and especially red is
gonna kill kill that guy on that's very
clever red is just ignoring ignoring the
the stuff yellow is doing because he
wants yellow to kind of use all his
pieces so what's funny about poor poet
chest is that sometimes if you work
together one guy can give a check and
then the next guy can give another check
and then it will be like a double check
and and all kinds of disasters for the
for the annuity guy but you can also see
that people are trying to create trouble
for each other and if one guy kind of
invites a cool attack then another guy
this is actually very cute it's a fork
with a pawn on two queens you don't see
that very often unfortunately if he
gives up this queen on the right hand
side which was a pawn that got wind then
I will only get the value of
at the pond so that's why it says one
because I will only get one point for
for taking this and consequently I'm
actually not going to take that Queen
because then I lose my most far advanced
pawn and I think I'd rather blue red
have to Queens than losing my chance of
getting to Queens I think so I'm gonna
do it and then you know somebody will
critique me and tell me what kind of
strategy I'm doing wrong I should see if
there's any chat going on which I'm
missing out on push that third pawn
yeah I should get all my pawns into the
attack
whatever happened to his Queen I turned
around for one moment and then the guys
queen disappeared and now I Queen my
pawn protected by the brook and this is
his real Queen if I get this one I will
get nine points so he will have to move
that and now suddenly I'm participating
in the attack on the blue King because
now I have a queen and I work on the
open file so I turned around to check
the the chat and suddenly my position is
I think overwhelming I think I have a
massive advantage here yeah and the guys
aren't really doing much I'm just gonna
go Queen another pawn why not my king is
pretty safe I have a lot of pieces
around my king guarding it and I'm just
gonna
get those Queens yeah I think this was
essentially my strategy from the
beginning let the other guys kill each
other and then hope that I'm alive to do
some damage afterwards yeah so chest
turin my queen when the pawn it's not
really reaches the center it's more like
when it steps across on the other side
of the board so this is half off the
board and then when you get across half
the board then it's a new queen I need
to make a move quickly before I lose
some time yeah okay and now red actually
prevented me from getting a new queen
and blue is just giving away his pieces
I don't think that's a good sign for me
I'd rather he he kept his pieces but now
I'm starting an attack there's a pin on
the Queen I have a bishop I'm using my
night on the f6 Knight no it's not f6
it's i3 it can really mess with your
head this game and this is good if I now
get my Bishop to f6 no I three then it's
also participating in the attack against
[Music]
against boos King so there's a this is
going to be a massive Bishop when I get
to take take back here that Bishop is
going to participate both ways both
against the Red King and against the
blue key
but now the thing is my next move is
very obvious I'm going to take this
bishop and that's often the occasion
people use to create some some
sufficient soup to create some
intermediate move and start attacking my
pieces or doing something that means
doing the obvious move of nerve
recapture would not be very very good
but I got away with it this time my
bishop pointing towards blue skin
pointing towards Reds King I also I'm
not that far behind on points I'm like
10 points behind that's not too bad and
now I have the opportunity of giving
checkmate so there's a check from the
Queen which means a double check is
checkmate so now I'm going to put my
queen here and give a checkmate so
that's oh that's often why you should be
careful about checking a very weak guy
because then some other guy can come in
and and give the the final blow and
thereby also giving all the points so
the red resigned and now we're both
trying to get to the king as quickly as
possible and I'm gonna be yellow to it
my queen is safe because of this there's
a dead pawn in the way and now he's just
giving me his queen I don't know if that
was a blunder but I'm getting a lot of
points these last few moves a lot of
points so now it's all about just
finishing the game yeah when you are up
by 20 points you can claim a win but the
thing is I'm not sure if you get more
rating
the more points you have and I've
actually asked the chest Kama guys about
this and they basically told me you have
to talk to some of the programmers
because the guy I asked actually didn't
know so I could I could resign here
thereby giving my opponent 20 points but
when we do the countdown I would still
be ahead so that's why I am the option
here on the side to claim a win I
actually cannot see it it's outside the
frame I made but I have the option of
claiming the win and some guys get
really upset when you don't claim the
win but if I get extra rating the more
the kind of the more points I get the
more the more vicious I was in in
winning the game then it makes sense to
play on because I mean if we just play
on I'm going to win this game for sure
points are irrelevant for the current
claim the win yo ok so the people are
saying that I should claim the win so I
I'm doing it but now I'm being told that
I can only claim on my turn
if I don't want to let him take my
knight and then kind of get away with it
so I'm gonna I claim the win now my guy
came second which is actually kind of
crucial you also get rating points for
second place but not as many as first
place as I understand it points are
irrelevant for the current rating system
you know the chat says but placement is
not irrelevant so you get more rating
for first place than you do for second
place
so yeah that's the way I'm gonna do
another gap I'm gonna try to have more
of a strategy in this game
the strategy of don't bother anyone and
just hope for the best is it's not
really a strategy that's gonna get you a
lot of fans so I'm gonna try to do the
strategy I did in my first couple of
games and that was pushing my rook pawn
at the earliest opportunity because
that's kind of the best way I think to
put pressure on your neighbors so I'm
gonna go with this rook pawn and then
kind of I'm to be honest I'm not sure
what I'm doing but I'm kind of
pretending to take control over some
squares in there yeah I don't know who
is the right highest rated player in for
player asks Jordan and you can find it
out by going into the chess calm for
player interface and you can go to the
leaderboard or top rated players you can
click and and see who is the current top
rated and now one of my opponents the
blue guy is actually watching the show
right now he's commenting in the chat so
I'll be careful to reveal any strategy
to him but luckily we are not neighbors
so I'm gonna be focused on red and
yellow those are gonna be my main
attacking targets
okay now a guy in the child is saying
rating points depend on other players
rating if high a high rated guy loses
all of the other opponents receive
points really I don't see how that can
be true if you come third and there was
a high rated guy in there you get points
yellow is being careless with his King I
don't see how he is he's about to Castle
and it's not like I was ready to give a
check at any point okay I'm starting to
push my pawns push those pawns now this
is interesting
red castled into my kind of area I'm
going to want to exploit that somehow so
yellow looks to be putting the King away
from me while red is putting his King in
my neighborhood so that's gonna be
[Music]
that's essentially going to be my
strategy I think okay I'm just gonna
keep pushing pause but so long as
nothing bad seems to be happy
maybe I can get some assistance from my
blue friend he's pointing his bishop
down towards red and he made a mistake
yeah but we could have taken this pawn
on whatever the square that is it's
ether teen ether teen blue could have
taken this pawn and only now white disk
yellow discovered it so he blocked with
his pawn
yeah now the typical queen race is
starting so blue is pushing his D pawn
red is pushing his D pawn and now yellow
is pushing pawns as well very often at
least one guy gets a new queen quite
early on because he's just pushing those
pawns but at this point we're quite far
into the game and if there are two
competing guys trying to get a queen
then basically they both cancel each
other out and just wasted a lot of time
for nothing so always when people are
pushing their central pawns I'm hoping
that some other guy will take care of it
because I want to be bothered trying to
stop him from getting a new queen I'm
hoping that somebody else will take that
responsibility which is egotistical for
sure but that's basically the essence of
the game that you hope that the other
guys through the exchanges so that you
you're left in a very good spot towards
the end of the game
what yeah actually I I thought I was
being the tricky one but I should be a
bit careful because red actually had the
option of giving blue my Brooke in which
case I would be in massive trouble so
let's go back and look at that when I
exchanged off my pawn here now there's a
possibility of red going forward with
his pawn and then it's blues move and
then blue can take my rook so I'll have
to be very careful of that so I
basically just protected my own work by
moving it one forward and it seems like
yellow is going to be the winner of the
new Queen race that's interesting
that's interesting so yellow is getting
a new queen and he's looking pretty
solid I'm right now I moved my bishop to
kind of point at yellows King at some
point
there's there's a guy in the chat who
whose name is triple-triple and Gotha
which is norwegian for triple fork and
he's commenting I want to see it's also
Swedish for for a triple fork and he
wants to see a queen checking all three
kings at the same time I've never
managed that so far but I have had some
some times I've had a queen that checks
two different opponents Kings at the
same time and you get extra points I
think for that at the very least you get
extra points for double checks I'll keep
pushing my pawns you get extra points
for double checks and triple checks I
think there there's got to be some
situations in which one king can be
checked by all three opponents at the
same time and then you get extra points
yeah now I'm in massive trouble because
bloom like I was talking about red
opened the file for the rook and I got
really lucky there because white had the
option of giving up his bishop and
making sure that I couldn't recapture
both both pieces at the same time but I
think essentially why they so happy with
his position he didn't want to give up
his bishop to mess with my position
because in his mind Green is not doing
anything Green is just being a spectator
to the game and not really accomplishing
anything so I think he decided that he
didn't want to give up a bishop to make
music which I think could be a good
decision because if he had taken then I
would have taken back with the check
so I would be in massive trouble against
blue but also he would be in some
trouble and he didn't want to give that
advantage to blue and red in terms of
doing exchanges let's see which pawn can
I advance this one Brandon is saying I
don't think red wants to do that because
you never want the person to the left to
benefit from things as theoretically has
an advance yeah no I I don't completely
follow you Brandon Braden but I very
much agree that it makes a big
difference whether a person is to your
left or to your right so basically I'm
too much of a beginner to understand the
point you're making you yeah and now I'm
getting in huge trouble against black
here no red
yeah I'm in massive trouble basically
I'm only hoping that yellow doesn't feel
like crushing my spirits because at this
point yellow could assist red in making
my life very miserable I think I made a
mistake by okay this is good this is
very good actually
yellow is disturbing red which means
maybe red cannot continue attacking in
the same way because now if red takes my
pawn here then yellow will take back
that pawn and both black kind of wants
to punish me
but he cannot give up his queen because
then I would take it yeah now it's
starting now it's starting to get
complicated
yeah only blue and red castled I agree
but it doesn't really matter whether you
Castle or not it's about how safe your
king is so my king didn't castle but
it's not safe however if I were to
castle right now I would just get
checkmated by white and this Queen
getting into because I've been pushing
my pawns so much so at this point I
think I just got a I don't know what to
do to be honest I mean I'm in big
trouble I can gamble that red
understands that it's not in both of our
best interests to do trades but if he
does trade then I'm going to be
massacred I know I should be using that
word today
I already got corrected for it to get
pretty much punished by you know and
that was a big mistake because now
yellow is just going to take my knight
because I cannot take it back
ah but I can move my Queen and then red
can take his Queen but on the other hand
I don't think red isn't much more to
help me out okay what just happened he
took something he took something at this
point I think if I just survive I have
okay chances with on the other hand I
don't see how there's any chance of me
surviving
yeah this is tricky
yeah calorics is basically clipping the
suggestion that I have used so many
times previously he says play passively
and they will forget all about so that's
essentially what I'm gonna do I'm just
gonna stick to my corner and hope that
they don't decide to checkmate me
because there are so many other pieces
and pawns hanging maybe they will get
busy taking pauses instead of
checkmating my King and I think if they
decided to do so I could so easily
checkmate me I'm my king is just
horrendous we placed
on the score it's actually very close
blue is leading with 12 points I'm in
the last place with six but I'm pretty
used to being in the last place so I
don't mind too much blue is one move
away from getting a new queen but since
I know he's listening I would strongly
advise you not to do that because I'm
just gonna take it okay so white is
doubling his Queens against my knight
and there's nothing I can do about it
depressing that's what it is
and I'm losing on time as well since the
person okay Brandon is coming back since
the person to your left has the biggest
chance to start a combo combination
attacking you meaning that they get a
check or take an important piece this
also means he has advantage over you so
in theory I should have an advantage
over yellow but my King position is so
so so bad that's simply not the case but
also red does have an advantage over me
and that's not good with the combination
of red having a massive attack actually
on this at this point red could have
taken on f8 check and then yellow would
have checkmated me by taking my knight
on c6 or whatever the squares are I get
confused and that would be good for
yellow because he gives checkmate which
is 20 points but on the other hand it
would also be good for red in terms of
their being one less player for the
second place spot a yellow has three
Queens so basically whatever happens are
I lost
yeah this is my problem with the delay
is that I don't actually I don't manage
to figure out when it's my turn because
when my clock is not moving I'm just I
figure it's probably somebody else's
turn it messes with your head okay I'll
try another game I didn't deserve to get
anything out of that I was going
completely my pawns weren't even close
to queening and hold the diagonals were
open towards my king yeah I'm getting
some hahaha in the chat which to be fair
I really deserve
especially when I tell you that is not
the first time I lose some time I mean I
have lost so many games on time it's you
know it's depressing really okay I'm
gonna try a new strategy now I'm gonna
do that since I'm red and the one who
moves first I'm gonna do the push the
pawn as far as you can go
strategy but unfortunately yellow had
the same idea which means we're gonna
mess up for each other so that's not
good
what
okay this is interesting I think both
white in both yellow and myself are
going to get new Queens if he now
understands that he should go one step
forward because I have no interest in
taking his pawn I'm just gonna go and do
a new queen okay he did not really
understand that I'm gonna block this
diagonal to make sure that my left
opponent doesn't have a check
I think that's solid reasoning
I need yellow to go one step forward so
that we can both queen but he's not
really feeling very cooperative at the
moment
okay I'm gonna block this diagonal as
well you know one step forward I have no
interest in taking your opponent I'm
gonna queen and then you're going to
Queen and then we're both going to
retreat our Queens making sure that we
both have the advantage of two Queens
yeah but he's not really following
following that scheme and now a blue is
coming and blue is basically trying to
take my phone he's just going to go 1 2
forward and then he can take my pawn all
right so now it's starting to be a bit
of a hurry
I need yellow to step forward yeah my
new reading the other game completed and
my writing got a massive kicking for
losing that oh it's my turn is it yeah
yeah I don't really
sometimes this pushing the pond to make
a new queen is very brilliant but if
some guy comes and stops you I mean what
are you gonna do then you just have
month development and no real plans but
on the other hand my normal strategy is
usually just doing nothing so pushing
the deep on trying to get a new queen or
in this case the Jeep on it feels like a
violent strategy
seeing as how if my main plan doesn't
work I'm just gonna be moving back and
forth for a very long time anyhow I
really need yellow to push the pawn
forward I mean he does understand I'm
never going to take that pawn I mean I
think if he only understood that we
would both Queens he would we would both
Queen I I think you would do it but I
have absolutely no interest in taking
your pawn please move it forward okay
and now blue is coming to the party as
well so that means I I gotta push it
forward
no but if I push it forward yellow is
going to take it and then I lose the
tempo I was a pawn he loses upon okay
I'm just gonna castle and wait for
better times
maybe the chat can help me out
push first and hope yellow doesn't
recapture that's the kind of strategy
that has worked horrendous ly for me the
past couple of days
whenever you hope that some guy is gonna
do something or not do something
works out never works out I mean people
are not very good at cooperating here
and they are very good at being mean and
ruining it for others and it in essence
I mean that's the right strategy that's
what you're supposed to do and how my my
pawn is getting trapped because both
blue and green are coming to to drop it
yeah but my King is a lot safer than it
normally is so even if I lose a pawn I
mean I think things are going okay
yeah so eight seven five six and the
chat makes basically the only point of
this game the and that is it's never
good to be exchanging pieces because if
you are two guys exchanging pieces it's
two guys not the the other two guys are
not exchanging pieces and that's just
yeah you would be giving your opponents
such a massive advantage by doing that
so in theory you shouldn't be exchanging
and then it never really works out the
way it's supposed to be yeah so Braden
is saying that I should make a solid
setup and basically use my opening to
defend my king okay so blue is inviting
a queen trade and I hate it when they do
that because they know that they're not
supposed to exchange Queens and they do
it anyway and it's just and then I have
to be the one the responsible one moving
away making sure that we don't exchange
pieces yeah
yet the Green King chest Horan is saying
that the green the green King is not
looking too great and I've I've seen
that as well
the Green Queen the green King is the
one I'm kind of pointing my pieces
towards it's just my bishop and my queen
but it's in the general direction of
green Wow now what get what why would he
take that part I mean I think I think
it's basically gambling that somebody is
gonna create trouble for me while while
this move is going on because otherwise
I'm getting a very nice pawn structure
and open file for my work so kind of
Green has to be creating some trouble
for me I guess the only way he could do
that is pushing the pawn forward but
it's not gonna do that
as sailors is kind of stating the
obvious in terms of there are many
different dynamics in four-player and
that is certainly true my problem is
that I haven't really kind of discovered
what those dynamics are so I'm kind of
still struggling with having some kind
of basic opening strategy
I basically crawl up in a corner or kind
of wait for the other ones to exhaust
themselves which i think is not really a
very positive way of playing but
effective I think but I think there's
one thing I do want to say that in a
four-point game like this if there were
teams if like red and yellow were on the
same team versus blue and green that
would be also a fantastic game and then
you would get to see so much more of the
cooperation and those possibilities in
the game suddenly I realized that yellow
is doing very very well yellow has like
three pawns close to queening where do
they Queen they Queen here yeah yellow
is doing pretty well and he's placing
his queen behind the pawn and one rook
behind the pawn yeah and he blundered
upon okay but he's winning a knight
aye aye sir posed I guess that's
something
yeah I have no idea what I'm too
yellow is good because green is passive
assess mr. Google but green passive I
don't know I think Green is in massive
trouble now because yellow is going to
take his night and then he's gonna have
to take back and then I'm going to take
this pawn very close to his king so
basically while yellow is doing a great
job of of taking greens pieces maybe I
will be the one who gets to give
checkmate oh wow
and speaking of that those are long
diagonals are so scary how long has that
been an option ah so that's sorry that's
tricky play from from blue he advanced
his pawn to open up the diagonal and
then he won with that he won that rook
on out here and how am I going to
checkmate green I'm gonna move my pieces
closer so I guess the night in here
somehow Wow now things are happening so
this is very good news for me blue and
yellow are basically trying to kill each
other and blue just blended a knight
here which I'm going to take on the next
move he's blue is so focused on yellow
that he's kind of ignoring what's going
on elsewhere Wow and now green is
hitting a new queen can I stop it
do I want to stop it I have no idea
well Green is not really doing too great
so if he gets a new Queen shouldn't be a
disaster I'll take this one
oh my rook is hanging yeah I have no
control over what's going on and also I
have a rook on this kind of file so if
yellow were to move his tonight then I
know the pawn doesn't go that way it
goes to this way yeah this is confusing
stuff okay I'm just gonna go back I
should really do something about this
rook maybe I'll move it
okay what's uh chance a rook rook work
our people have been telling me that my
work is hanging and I just haven't been
10 paying attention well yeah I
ventually I saw it eventually I saw it
if two people are killing each other go
for the third says mr. Google and that I
think is excellent advice so I should go
for green and as I say that I realized
that I have blundered my pawn down here
and in that case Green has two Queens
ready to give to checkmate me and I got
away with it that's insane
so if green had taken this pawn then I
would be just completely dead so I'm not
paying attention and I'm getting really
lucky multiple times
yeah I got a headache I gotta be honest
this game is giving me a headache okay
it's my turn again let's just move the
pieces back yeah no it's more fun to go
forward
threatening a queen fork going after
yeah but that's this is the reason I
shouldn't have moved that night right
because now he's threatening my queen
and then Greene is going to threaten my
bishop and then I'm going to lose a
piece because I cannot protect both at
the same time
I'm getting a question in the chat is
this habit time or hammered hammered
time oh I I thought you were essentially
making a joke about hammered time
hammered I think that's what you were
saying but yeah I'm getting crushed I
think but it's so hard to tell everybody
has about the same amount of points and
if I just stop moving pieces away from
my king then I think I have the know
actually maybe blue has been more safe
King
so yeah blue is actually the one doing
best here and now Green is offering
exchanges that's basically the cardinal
rule you don't do exchanges but I don't
see any other good bishops are almost as
good as Queens yeah I agree
but I'd rather not lose any of those
quad radical is saying this is so funny
blues pawns cannot be taken by green or
red because of each other
red is me what are you saying that I
can't do I can do anything and right now
I feel like moving pieces toward greens
King actually on the next note I'm
moving my bishop down here and then I'm
gonna try to do some checking with my
queen
what yellow just bundle made in one but
that also means that I get the Queen for
free maybe that's good for me
I don't know ah but it also means that
blue is just marching towards more
queens with his central pawns yeah I
think blue is taking this one home for
sure play with the Queen you can make
green that was directed at me and it
does feel like I should be listening to
that advice but on the other hand if I
now take this bishop then blue gets
additional points for a double check
because he's getting a queen when he
takes my knight yes i i'm just don't
really seen i don't see how I can do
anything about blue I think blue is just
winning so easily okay but my knight is
attacked so I should move it right and
then blue will make two new Queens I'm
kind of working under the assumption
that I will be green no matter what but
maybe I should be thinking about making
sure that I finish second blue is
probably gonna win no matter what so I
should make sure that I finished second
so maybe I should try to kind of help
blue into checkmating green because then
at least I will make second place if
that makes sense yeah I'm a bit low on
time why are you taking off yeah I
thought it was protected by greens Queen
but of course I gave a check to green
okay but if I just let blue take the
green Queen no blue is definitely going
to win he's very well coordinated and he
has good pawns and stuff and many more
pieces than me but right now I'm focused
on making sure I finish ahead of green
so now I I'm Anna to block the
prospective Queen that's good
it's actually very good I think
what advice am i getting we maybe made a
mistake if blue is the one to checkmate
Green then I'm not sure I'm gonna get
enough points to get ahead of Green
do not play a rook to protect that rook
let us work together against blue please
do not mess up yes thank you you never
know what people are gonna do suddenly
they will decide to team up against you
I think actually that would have been a
smart move from from green if he had
gone with his rook because he's green
kind of has to realize that he's not
doing very well and therefore he should
kind of help blue kill me I think okay
so I'm gonna go for the checkmate I'm
gonna let no I don't think that blue can
get a new Queen any time soon
yeah now when we was actually doing me
some favors I don't think that was a
good move because any time Green cannot
move then I'm being helped in the
direction of checkmate and green so I
think that Bishop check may have been a
mistake because it wastes one move on
the bishop check and then also make sure
that black know that Green cannot do
anything while I check made him maybe
I'm not gonna check meet him as easily
as I would have hoped
it's not entirely clear blue is doing
very well at the moment yeah blues
thinking I think he's regretting some of
his choices okay if I take the rook then
he takes here no he goes forward I want
to make sure I'm not helping out green
too much either
I gotta make him move fast because my
time is running out
and this is a bit of a bug I sometimes I
don't actually get to know that um my
time is running so there I was very
close to losing on time which is also
why I've been losing so many games on on
time things kind of haven't tend to see
Oh going south suddenly and then you
start thinking and then everything goes
wrong I don't know what my strategy
should be now
okay
this is interesting green is helping me
out with messing up blue that's very
interesting I don't have enough time to
kind of ponder the consequences I assume
I'm almost ahead of blues now I'm going
to beat blue and I'm in a position to
beat green I think so I think I'm just
gonna sit quietly and kind of hope that
they kill each other
check
at the very least let me know sometime I
think
that is the problem with people you
cannot rely on them such an
untrustworthy guy I should have seen
that coming and now I'm third I really
thought I had this under control
why is he just letting green get another
queen is that part of his strategy of
making my life miserable
I think he's basically just asking go
checkmate blue you have checkmate in two
moves thank you that's very kind just go
checkmate blue checkmate in one move in
one move thank you okay and now the
question is is he going to claim a win
because if he claims to win then I get
second place but if he doesn't claim a
woman I'm going to lose because I have
no chance of getting kind of taking any
of his pieces which is why I kind of
think this whole claiming a win thing
it's a bit ridiculous but it because it
really does affect who gets second place
and who gets third place so I'm eight
points behind
so I basically need to get not
checkmated while somehow taking eight
points and that's never gonna happen
yeah so I'm gonna get Satan a third
place and then I'm gonna lose more
rating and then I'm gonna be more
depressed and I'm gonna keep going on
about this game being very very tricky
just let me take a rug
I'm just a rook away from getting second
place I don't think he will care too
much about my feelings I don't think so
no I guess my best chance is hoping that
he will exchange rooks but I don't think
he's gonna do that that's a third place
finish for play chess has been launched
by chess calm its occasionally fun very
often just a complete heartbreak
blunders diagonals you minced things
that go wrong are very prominent in for
play chess there is some kind of
strategy to it I have had a lot of great
input in the chat today but
unfortunately I'm not yet at the level
where I actually understand anything
what's going on if you want quick
results good results early on in for PHS
my advice to you is to stay quiet stay
in your corner make sure your king is
safe and hope that the other guys spend
too much time killing each other to
notice that suddenly you're a queen or a
row
or massive material up make sure that
you always have kind of one attacking
piece because often people make mistakes
that they give a check on a very weak
guy and then you can come in for the
finishing checkmate even though you
really didn't have any credit to the guy
getting cheque made it in the first
place let me see the check if there are
some some any good any good tips for
beginning players
this is nuts
says for Thor s even a grandmaster
doesn't win trust me
this game is much much harder than chess
I look forward to trying again with you
sometime yeah and until then have fun
teach me more for playing chess
and yeah see you guys later